يظهر مقطع فيديو جديد ما يمكن أن يكون
أول مشاهدة مسجلة لسمكة
قرش بيضاء كبيرة حديثة الولادة في البرية، حيث
التقط مخرج أفلام الحياة البرية هذه الصور بطائرة بدون طيار على بعد
400 متر قبالة ساحل كاليفورنيا،
ويقول الباحثون إن الشكل والحجم يتطابقان مع شكل وحجم
المولود الجديد، وأنهم  نعتقد أنه
كان يتخلص من طبقته الجنينية، لكن
بعض الخبراء يصفون هذا الاكتشاف بأنه
تخميني للغاية، ويقول آخرون بغض النظر
عما نعرفه، إنها تظل
ملاحظة مثيرة تعطي المزيد من الأدلة حول المكان الذي
قد تكون فيه أرض خصبة فعلية،
وينضم إلي الآن المخرج الذي التقط
تلك الصور.  كارلوس جينر هو
مصور فوتوغرافي ومخرج أفلام عن الحياة البرية، وهو
ينضم إلي الآن من كاليفورنيا، ومن دواعي سروري أن
تكون معنا، شكرًا لك، شكرًا لاستضافتي،
لذا قمت بالتقاط هذه
اللقطات الرائعة قبالة ساحل
جنوب كاليفورنيا والتي تظهر ما
يمكن أن يكون أول لمحة على الإطلاق لطفل
حديث الولادة  سمكة قرش بيضاء كبيرة في البرية،
لماذا تعتقد أن هذا ما
نراه هنا وما مدى أهمية
هذا الأمر
أولاً وقبل كل شيء، أه ليس هناك
سابقة لهذا، فنحن لا نعرف
بالضبط كيف يبدو القرش الأبيض حديث الولادة.  من
الصعب التفكير
في الأمر بشكل صحيح، لذلك اه نعتقد أن هذا
مولود جديد اه لعدة أسباب، أحدها
اه الحجم والشكل المحدد
للزعنفة الظهرية وجميع الزعانف
اه مستديرة
اه إذا نظرت إلى  سمكة قرش بيضاء
صغيرة الحجم ومتطورة ولها زعانف
ظهرية مدببة للغاية، وهذه السمكة لها زعنفة ظهرية مستديرة جدًا
غير متطورة، وهذا أحد الأسباب، والسبب
الثاني هو أنها تفقد أو
تقشر طبقة من الطلاء الأبيض
الذي نعتقد أنه يمكن أن يكون آه
بطانة حليب الرحم من
الأم، فماذا تقول لهؤلاء
الخبراء الذين يسمون هذه النتيجة
تخمينية للغاية وكيف يمكن
التأكد من أن هذا هو سمكة قرش بيضاء كبيرة حديثة الولادة،
هل
من الممكن ذلك جيدًا في مخطوطتنا
أه في المجلة  لقد
نشرنا فرضيتين، الأولى أنه
في الواقع حديث الولادة ولدينا مجموعة من
الحقائق أه ثم الثانية هي
أنه قد تكون حالة جلدية، هذه
الطبقة البيضاء التي تتساقط أثناء
سباحة القرش أه  المشكلة
في الفرضية الثانية وما أه
الناس الذين يقولون إنها حالة جلدية
هو أن ذلك لا يفسر
الشكل الفريد للمروحة الظهرية في
الزعانف الصدرية بحجم
سمكة القرش